alors vous le savez ces dernières
semaines j'ai fait quelques tentatives
pour savoir si les gens qui
m'entouraient c'est à dire vous était un
peu connus ou juste des mythomanes
je vais pas vous mentir oui c'est
compliqué jusqu'à présent donc
régulièrement on fera des petits
contrôle pour voir si ça évolue
là en plus je voulais tester les
nouvelles comme daniel hains et caroline
j'y vois plus clair cerveau grâce à un
focus group eric besson font vous allez
voir ils sont à croquer alors cette
semaine il fallait des spécialistes pour
répondre à des questions essentielles
pour les enfants je vais vous montrer
des photos de personnalités
vous allez me dire déjà si vous les
connaissez si vous paraît sympathique
d'accord alors parce que vous connaissez
cette personne macron macro minimes coin
voilà
et avec cet homme à la tête de la france
est ce que tu es en confiance
oui il se la pète un peu maintenant
s'assurer on voit ses dents qu'est ce
que tu lui conseille de faire à jean
michel mr blanchiment est ce que vous
trouvez sympathique ne dit la vérité oui
des fois je me dis que c'est boubers mes
bébés il ya quelque chose parce que vous
connaissez déjà
non mais quelle est bizarre parce qu'ils
tombaient très bien et son aile et il a
une tête à faire quel est le type de
métier il travaille le travail très joli
métier
chenet une règle ou d'islande
la reine d'islande elle s'appelle
isabelle mot bons mots là je pense que
j'ai fait diplo tease et on passe au
suivant
il s'appelle manuel mâcon média matters
lorsque tous les matches et de l'armée
matthieu delormeau enduré il a fait de
la chirurgie esthétique pour hommes
c'est surtout c'est surtout un peu de
travers ils sont un peu de travers il
est moche parce que vous la connaissez
déjà un avion c'est à dire c'est un
avion de chasse la d'avion elle a une
tête de puits ouais c'est vrai toit
rebecca et inspire à cette dame
même lit pas ce qu'elle paraît
sympathique nous pourquoi n'ont elles
ont l'air bien l'inquiétude c'est à dire
de changer de torches à vaugneray et bk
je connais ma base on a vu depuis début
mai tu tues maîtresse bien aimé lyonnais
prend on passe au suivant
danseuse direct
elle fait danser avec les stars mal à
l'aise parce que tu l'as vu dans quelle
émission tout ça n'existe en fait
travail fait travail d'hier et caroline
roux sauveur non c'est une vendeuse de
maïs à mountain view
voilà 10 euros à un moment on va te
faire souffler dans un ballon je vois
c'est très rigolo
ouais c'est juste pour vérifier quelque
chose par carolin turbide
[Applaudissements]
d'accord tu es au passage suivant armées
je le connais alexandre vignoble a donc
là c'est alexandre bédat la ba oui il
s'appelle cyril cyril hanouna le fameux
là nous n'allons est vraiment fou
dangereux ou fou sympa fou dans le fond
de moi je sais fait point comitié 20
points chroniqueur lui c'est il sera
pour le che se puisse et des bêtises
d'accord je préfère les chroniqueurs
ouais je suis bien j'aime bien cette
idée
[Applaudissements]